well you know I I take a really long  time to write the scripts uh when I  write I I wish I wish it took me less  time but I feel like part of what I do  is  um as I you know it's grounded in  something that's very close to my heart  but I really in invent these characters  and I try to let them talk to me and I  think on an interesting way writing they  always say acting is about listening but  also writing is about listening it's  about listening to your characters  because you'll find that they tell you  things that you didn't even know that  they had in them and then it sort of  it's It's the mystery of of writing and  where it comes from in you or where  where it's been gathered from and I just  um I just spend a lot of time with these  people and so by the time I have a draft  of the movie it's really a  representation of just it's like I've  hung out with them for a couple years